[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we bring in doug gottlieb host of the
doug gottlieb show on fox sports radio
fox sports college basketball analyst
doug joining us from indianapolis as
he's doing the big ten tournament on
compass radio uh recapping what we just
heard
uh duke right now that game against
florida state
is not going to be played because
somebody
on the staff team has tested positive
for covid we don't know that
but it feels like duke's season is
probably over
uh i'm wondering about the rest of the
acc tournament
here uh doug what what's going to happen
here
i i don't know i mean you have to
obviously have contingency plans
uh because you know you have contact
tracing
and then you know what happens with
anyone else who came in contact with
but what what you asked the question are
they done done
i was just texting with jeff and the
logic is it again it's not contact
tracing
it's somebody has a positive test right
so that means then there's the
there's a there's a quarantining and i'm
in indy where
they moved all the big ten teams here
and then the big ten teams that advanced
the tournament are going to stay here
for up to a month
and of course they have the extra the
tournament's going to start a day later
you know again so that there's a little
extra quarantining and it's
it becomes a bubble but i mean this is
this is part of the issue
i guess my question is this i understand
that first responders and senior
citizens
uh need to get the vaccine why are we
not backstage players
i don't somebody explain that to me i
know that adam silver came out so we're
not going to make our players get
vaccinated i've talked to nba coaches
nba players they are generally getting
vaccinated
you know without without broadcasting it
i just i don't understand why
we're going we should go to all these
leaps but here's something that
that people don't know so i i did the
the socon conference
two days ago three days ago and then the
caa
the team that loses still has to test
for five days
their season normally done like mercer
mercer lost to unc greensboro they have
to test for five days because
if greensboro has positive tests green's
unc greensboro doesn't go
mercer does go if they don't have
positive tests it's it's a oh it's just
a wacky year and obviously we're on the
one year anniversary of sports
shutting down and here duke is the
the biggest program in college
basketball losing any chance of a post
season because of one positive test
did they need that win over florida
state to get into the tournament
yes yes i mean look louisville helped
um but you know they had an initial bump
there
late in the season but it just it wasn't
enough
you know they're just they had sustained
too many losses
and people have to understand that the
acc is
really down this year and i mean like
look it's really hard to tell
a lot of things like louisville for
example they played wisconsin this year
with i think six or seven guys but they
didn't have four starters
so they lost by 50 to wisconsin this is
around christmas time
it's hard to tell sometimes results of
who actually is good and then some of
these
teams have come out of two three weeks
of corn team and they play a game
and they're not really representative of
that's why i mean i want to get
i wanted to come on and say like hey
there's a couple teams out there like
oregon people should bet on because
they're going to be massively under
seated because of
all the litany of things that went on in
their season but this obviously
trumps that how did duke get here in the
first place doug it feels like they had
a top five recruiting class don't they
have a top
five recruiting class every year no well
you have to understand it
it's different there's a couple things
that went against them okay first
um you have you know the the top three
freshmen in the country right um suggs
goes to jalen suggs goes to gonzaga
and then cade cunningham instead of
going to north carolina or kentucky
he goes to oklahoma state and then you
know usc has evan mobley his dad's on
staff
and he goes to usc so you cut out three
of
the top five top ten then you count out
three or four more
who were going to go to college or maybe
you want jalen green for example and
they go to the g league ignite
so you basically cut out the top 10 from
kentucky and from duke then you factor
in you know
you lose your point guard um you know
you lose your you know they they're not
taking the depth of transfers that other
people are taking
um and they're just you you don't
replace
it's really hard when you can't replace
stars with other stars
and now the sudden you're at the same
place as everybody else and then you
throw in
the quarantining and some of the stuff
and um they're not alone
this is kentucky same thing they've made
some of them made some bad choices in
terms of who they've taken
but i think this is a big story in
college basketball in that
the blue bloods who normally feast on
those top 10 top 15 guys
now they're recruiting 15 to 25 or 15 to
50
and those are good players but they're
not the type of
impact players who come you know they're
not zion williams
you know they're not kate cunningham
they're not jaylen green they're not
kids that can just
carry you to an ncaa tournament they
don't have those guys and that's
that's why kentucky's down that's why
kansas is down that's why duke is down
it's because the players more than
anything else these teams that won't
make
the ncaa tournament can you see them
going to the nit
i mean i would i mean more basketball
right like all these guys say like well
you know you go you go to their ig page
and their ball is life guys now
all i want to do is hoop but the reality
is probably not remember the last time
kentucky went to the nit it was an
abject disaster you know it's like when
an sec school gets
left out of the college football playoff
and they just no show in a bowl game and
some guys you know opt out
i i i would guess no i would guess it's
a and for people who don't know
it's at north texas at the super pit
they're gonna have 16 teams in a bubble
it'd actually be pretty cool um but i
would guess no
he's doug gottlieb host of the doug
gottlieb show on fox sports radio and of
course
covering the big ten tournament there
how many teams get in from the big ten
all of them let's just put them all in
every every one oh we tell you
we gotta put them all in not indiana
and let's put penn state in
and india i don't know what you do dan i
mean there's some indiana's bad man
they've lost a lot of games late i i
don't know how you
it's it's just weird though because you
have i was finished strong obviously
michigan
won the league but again michigan
because of shutdown they didn't play at
illinois they played illinois once
didn't have their best player and they
got housed by illinois
um but you got this group minnesota
i don't think they're getting in they
you know even though they won last night
but they didn't win a road game all year
but they crushed michigan when they
played him at their place
there's this list i you know my guess
would be somewhere around
seven and just throw them in a hat once
you get once you get past the big boys i
think michigan state's getting in
i think rightfully so and i do think the
win over duke way back when helps and
then of course
beating michigan here last game of the
regular season helps
uh the acc's the question to me and i
know i live west coast and i'm
by the way thank you to let me fill in
for you even though i know everybody
complains that i suck comparison to you
um but i get a chance to see
the west coast schools and the the
mountain west has a couple teams that
are really good like utah state
and boise that they by my estimation
belong in but what do i know about
basketball only played it and covered it
for like 20 years
um so i think it's gonna be interesting
because there is
there's always been a slight east coast
bias but i've never been with these east
coast bias guys but because the west
coast schools
have gone through such a difficult
season with shutting
down and not having their guys and not
being able to practice
i mean stanford played like four home
games all year i know they got blown out
last night by cal they're terrible but
the point is it it was much harder to
get the team to look right in the west
coast and i do think that
there's a little bit of benefit of the
doubt that should go to a couple of
those schools
how much wiggle room does john calipari
have at kentucky
like is he on the hot seat or a warm
seat
no but but i do think like
college basketball is a change in here
right like you're gonna have to be
more creative in recruiting you know you
take some guys
recently taking players that transferred
up right that's when you're at a low
major mid major some have hit some have
missed
um they're gonna start have to be
creative in terms and they're gonna have
to do better player evaluations
um but you know like they took here's
for example they took devin askew who's
from modern day high school in southern
california
he could have been a high school senior
this year so
um and obviously he's had a
disappointing season
but um i so i they have to do a better
job of valuing the point guard position
better job value of players but i also
think that you're playing against older
kids i mean the reason the big ten
schools are better is they have the
highest precipitous rate
you know they have older dudes that are
back so wisconsin has two guys starting
in their starting lineup 24 years old
like a 24 year old's gonna be better
than a 19 18 19 year old just
kind of kind of facts so um i think some
of it is
the changing landscape of college
basketball how how hot is this hot seat
i i i don't think you can have another
season like this one this is a this is a
bad year
it's a bad year and next year if you had
another one of these
they would be like hey what are we doing
here uh do you want to rethink things
but you know he lost his ace recruiter
to the nba
and maybe maybe everybody knew what was
coming and this is what was coming
because it is not good
and the g-league selecting is going to
continue to take
five or ten kids and you know more and
more schools are gonna hire parents or
siblings or whatever
and the trends are here you gotta find a
way to get old and
stay old if you want to win in college
basketball are we making enough of
gonzaga's undefeated regular season
going undefeated into the tournament
should we be making more of it
i don't know i mean kentucky finished
undefeated a couple years ago um
so it has wichita state undefeated a
couple years ago and there's kind of
apparent the difference in gonzaga
and wichita state is they played some of
the big boys they didn't play baylor
like they're supposed to but they played
some of the big boys school in the year
and i mean they they were so much better
than kansas uh it was it was silly
they have like three or four nba players
and a couple dude they only play like
six or seven
they're really really good like i've
been kind of playing with twitter all
year
with the gonzaga or the field and i
think baylor's
close and i think you know michigan and
illinois are close but they're
i mean i don't know if you saw the other
night they played byu late byu put up 53
couldn't play better in the first half
and and you know gonzaga just
downshifted and jaylen suggs just took
over late
they're they're good they're competitive
they have bigs uh
they're not great defensively but they
have two point guards
kid named andrew nemhart who's from um
i started at florida for two years to
play in two point so
athletic ball handling is not a problem
shooting's not a problem
they've been to a national championship
game before like people think gonzaga
choke they're the only school to be in
the last five sweet 16s
gonzaga is legit i don't think we're
making a big enough deal of it because
we do have a tendency to think of
gonzaga's you know uh adam morrison
crying
and the loss to ucla more so than we
remember they're one possession away
from winning the national championship a
couple years ago
they're the real deal and no we're not
because they play in the wcc but
what's weird about it is you and i are
old enough to remember 30 years ago
unlv was in a far weaker league in the
it was the pc double a was the big west
then i can't remember
right and nobody said anything about
their league memphis was in
conference usa nobody we said a little
bit about their league was more about
free throw shooting
they were dominant in lesser leagues and
people
didn't make didn't diminish their record
because their league we do that again
about gonzaga and i'm not
really sure why good to talk to you
there
have fun play nice uh in indianapolis
doc
what why do you only want to see one
video of my son's wet jump shot
oh my god i can't fix my jump shot my i
could fix my son's junction
doug's i i doug sent me a video he said
oh i heard you ran on steph curry so he
sends me a video of his son
in a he's 11 years old playing a pickup
game or some game there
and i didn't know it was your son
because he made the three that's what i
thought was
that that kind of surprised me a little
bit and then doug wants to send me
another video and i go
one video per day doug good god
maybe i'm tr i'm proud of the guy but he
does it you're you're right dude i mean
like the steph curry range thing
is a real thing and uh
it's it's changed the way in coaching
kids you look at what's a good shot
what's a bad shot and we were always
taught
like that's the thing about you're
talking about larry bird i disagree with
you
like bro magic johnson you forget how
good he was back in dudes down like
old-school one-on-one ball like backing
down
obviously the guys are more athletic now
because of the training
that would be in their primes a much
more competitive game than you're
you forget how good larry you don't
forget i've been doing it right
oh no i'm just saying lebron and kd can
do what they want to do on the floor
magic's brilliance is still seeing the
floor not necessarily being a great
scorer
yeah but hold on though hold on though
the the baby skies i got it
i got it i got it but dave you know
larry couldn't guard me
so now you're gonna guard he's guarding
kd i mean come on that's not fair if you
said
michael and larry now we have a
conversation doug magic
and larry no no i take katie and lebron
i think look i think they're new and
improved versions of each other but i do
like the the the one the point to me
that i was trying to make
is is that we we just people i chris
mullen told me this like they used to
discourage people from shooting
three-point shots not that he couldn't
shoot it
right i mean larry bird the volume of
threes weren't there
as you remember he won the three-point
shooting contest without taking off the
warm-up jack
walked in the locker and said who's
getting second shot the last one had the
one finger in the air walked off the
court right so he could
there was a lot of things that he could
do that he wasn't encouraged to do
the way we encourage them to do now
because we've learned how to work
smarter not harder
that clears that up now you can send me
another video of your son
shooting today one per day right now you
know
well let me go to break so i can get
that thank you doug
that's uh doug gottley he'll uh be
working in indianapolis big ten
tournament